take a look at the roof of these four
houses can you spot which one is covered
in solar cells that's a trick question
because they all this list first ever
solar product is stunning it's not a
solar panel instead it's a range of for
solar roofing material that look
virtually indistinguishable from high in
terracotta slate or slick modern add
function people really care about their
homes they love their homes and they
really wanted to be better I think
taking this approach take Avenue
here's how it works the top of the roof
tile is made of textured glass it looks
like shingles from most angles but it
allows sunlight to pass through from
above and into a standard solar cell
with almost no loss in efficiency
Tesla says the glass is the toughest
field and can weather a lifetime of
abuse from the elements it can also be
fitted with heating elements to melt off
snow and colder climate active solar
tiles will cost about 42 dollars per
square foot cheaper than traditional
shingles with solar panels on top but
ultimately you'll probably need more
tiles to do the same job so Tesla's
total roof cost could be a bit high you
want to call your neighbors over and say
check up check out the sweet roof like
on a phrase that you hear often it this
represents the grand unification of
Tesla's plans to become a Sun to vehicle
energy company the idea is that you can
run your home on solar power store it in
a swim battery that hangs on your wall
and then use that electricity to power
your home and Clark this combination is
perhaps the closest we've ever come to
affordable off-grid electricity the goal
is to make solar roofs that look better
than normal roof generate electricity
have last longer a better insulation and
actually have an installed cost that is
less than a normal roof plus the cost of
electricity so then why would you buy
anything else the solar roof was Musk's
closing argument to shareholders before
their vote to approve Tesla's 2.2
billion dollar bid to buy the biggest
u.s. rooftop solar installer solar city
to make it all possible there are plenty
of reasons to be skeptical but it must
include off this trifecta of Tesla
products - solar roof the power wall -
in the model 3 electric car will be
available in Tesla stores across the US
and at the end of 2017
[Music]
you